مهاجع الفتيات قد اتى عليها الحريق الوافد
محطمه هذا ما اصبح عليه حال مدرسه تبوك
الثانويه قبل شهر من الان حلم الطالبات
تمت سرقته من المئات المختطفات من فراش هم
لو لم يكن اليوم قد وقعنا بالتحديد كانت
الطالبات في قضيه الامتحانات في هذه
المدرسه وتلك الامتحانات يفترض ان تكون
بوابه لل مستقبل مشرق لهم يمكن ان ياخذ من
خارج تبوك وخارج التي يخيم عليها بوكو
حرام بالنسبه للعديد من الفتيات رغم
الايمان بالمستقبل المشرق لكنه مستقبل
يكتنف الغموض تعليم البنات في نيجيريا
خطيئه في نظر بوكو حرام الجماعه الارهابيه
التي اعلنت مسؤوليتها عن هذا الدمار
بالنسبه لاحد الفتيات التي حالفها الحظ
بالهرب من خاطفيها كانت رساله فهمتها
بوضوح اذا كان في شيء وكلنا اعود مره اخرى
لا تريد ان العوده الى المدرسه لانهم اخاف
وكي
نعم ماذا كنت ستصبحين طبيبه تريدين ان
تكوني طبيبه نعم كم يبدو هذا صعب المنال
دانيال موفي وعائلته هربوا الى الاحراج
ليله الهجوم ولحسن الحظ هم معا في امان
ولكن ما شاهدوه تلك الليله ما زال يشكل
لهم صدمه هذه المنطقه كانت تحت الحصار
لسنوات
الخوف في كل مكان حاليا ما شاهدناه يحدث
لبناتنا هنا الان ياكلوا تهرب واللواتي
مازلنا مقتطفات من مدارس ان هناك سؤال مهم
يدور في ذهن كلاب حول ما يمكن ان نفعله
لحفظ حياه اطفالنا عندما يوصلهم الى
المدارس لانه لا احد يمكن ان يتحمل فقدان
ابنه لكنهم لم يفقدوا الامل بشكل تام فهو
يصلي اجل ان ياتي يوم يمكن لبناتهم ان
يتحرر ليضمنوا مستقبلهن ماذا تريد لبنات
كان يصبح نا عندما يكبر شيء مثل محاميات
طبيبات مهندسات لانني عندما اشاهد هؤلاء
الناس يقومون بعملهم اشعر بالرغبه والامل
بان يصبح ابنائي مثلهم لديك عمل الكبير
فيهم نعم امال كبيره جدا بهم نعم